[Musique]
karine mousseau bonjour bonjour monsieur
caruge vous êtes candidate aux élections
municipales de mars 2020 vous vous
présentez au françois
vous y retourner peut-on dire puisque en
2014 vous étiez déjà candidate est alors
qu'entre temps vous avez été élue
conseillère territoriale et que vous
avez le mandat de président du comité
martiniquais du tourisme
pourquoi avoir choisi karen mousseau de
retourner de retenter cette expérience
m'a écouté c'est très simple avec
d'abord bonjour à tous ceux qui nous
écoutent et en particulier aux
franciscains des franciscains ce qui me
motive c'est simple je suis franciscaine
mes souvenirs d'enfant sont au françois
d'adolescence aussi et aujourd'hui je
vis au françois je travaille au françois
on va dire que je vis le françois vous
êtes conseiller municipal d'opposition
de l'hérault et vivre lefrançois c'est
aussi comprendre qu'on a un potentiel
extraordinaire
donc je vais aux élections parce que je
rêve d'en françois rassemblée unie
solidaire
je rêve d'en françois où il fait bon
vivre au quotidien
c'est très important je rêve d'en
françois enfin au niveau de son
potentiel de développement économique et
en particulier de développement
touristique
et puis je veux rajouter souviens pas
entendre vous aurez vous aurez le loisir
de développer un peu tout à l'heure sur
les rêves d'un françois qu'ils soient
enfin dans la voie du développement
durable de la protection de
l'environnement parce que nous ne
pouvons pas scier la branche sur
laquelle nous sommes assis alors vous
pourrez détaillé un petit peu ça nous
donnait un ou deux exemples de
propositions que vous avez à faire à la
population franciscaine mais tout de
même on me rappelle beaucoup de gens le
sachent mais vous êtes issu des rangs de
l air les républicains martinique entre
temps pour donc ce mandat à la
collectivités territoriales vous avez
été élu avec l'alliance bas payant
chance ce que je veux vous demander
carmine russo sait comment avez vous
constituez votre liste au françois
est ce que c'est une liste qu'on peut
qualifier de droite ou issus de l air ou
est ce qu'elle est multicarte j'en ai
tellement pas aujourd'hui évidemment
françois doz boat est une liste ouverte
à toutes les franciscaines et à tous les
franciscains qui veulent s'investir pour
leur commune vous avez avec cette équipe
justement qui est une équipe m'a formé
de personnes de tous horizons leurs
visages le nom du louvre en soi de boot
cette équipe françois de boot nous
sommes sur le terrain depuis plus d'un
an à la rencontre des franciscaines et
franciscains et je voulais vraiment
savoir comment vivent les franciscains
aujourd'hui quels sont leur retour ce
qui va ce qui ne va pas quelle est leur
quotidien
on se rend compte effectivement qu'il
faut retourner dans les quartiers
notamment ces quartiers où les gens se
sont finalement abandonnée et ça va être
vraiment aidé un de nos objectifs
prioritaires retourner dans les
quartiers mettre en place des comités de
quartier pour que les francis kahn et
les franciscains comprennent qu'on se
rapproche d'eux et qu'on qu'on
entretienne enfin nos quartiers la
deuxième chose que nous voyons sur le
terrain que je vois aussi avec
l'expérience que vous avez cités tout à
l'heure c'est notre potentiel comme je
voulais dit de développement économique
et touristique
aujourd'hui 200 mille touristes vont à
l'habitation clément
combien d'entre eux viennent visiter
notre bourg viennent visiter nos
campagnes viennent sur la marina pour
prendre un pot ou simplement se
restaurer viennent visiter nos il est
très peu nous avons un potentiel
extraordinaire au niveau touristique
nous devons explorer exploitée mais
qu'est ce qui se passe c'est quoi c'est
l'attractivité de la commune l activité
c'est quoi l'équipe en place qui n'a pas
su faire selon vous et quoi écouter
c'est l'attractivité c'est une vision
cette vision nous l'avons à françois
dubout de gelée pour ma commune du
françois
et dans dix ans dans 20 ans j'aimerais
qu'elle soit parmi les communes qui
rayonne le plus en martinique comme le
club franciscain est le meilleur club de
foot de la martinique nous devrions être
l'un de meilleurs l'onu
moi je suis un pécheur
nous devrions être parmi les communes
qui rayonne le plus et tous nos projets
qu'ils soient les projets de court terme
ou structures en jugeront pourcet
revient ces objectifs-là de rayonnement
de la commune avant vous avant de vous
demander justement quel serait votre
première priorité si une fois que vous
seriez lui et que vous accédez à la
mairie du françois
juste un mot vous pensez que ce sera
facile parce que il ya un contexte
particulier maurice antiste qui était le
maire élu en 2014
entre temps à démissionner son
successeur
monsieur lausanne ne se présente pas le
premier adjoint ne se présente pas non
plus est-ce que donc il ya beaucoup de
candidats à nouveau y compris vous mais
même si ça fait quelques années que vous
êtes sur la scène politique est ce que
c'est pour vous une chance particulière
a pu écouter rien n'est jamais facile
mais je crois qu'aujourd'hui en six ans
les choses ont changé les franciscaines
et les franciscains me connaissent ils
me connaissent dans mes responsabilités
politiques
ils connaissent mes compétences ils
connaissent ma volonté ils connaissent
ma force de travail ils savent les
valeurs qui me porte l'honnêteté la
justice
ils savent que je suis quelqu'un qui en
veut ils connaissent aussi mon franc
parler et je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est
ça qui fera la différence très bien donc
je n'ai qu'une chose à dire mais tu es
en forme de goutte pour françois louw
boot est le premier dossier que vous
prendriez en main audit financier
restructurer l'organigramme pour que
tous nos projets se fasse le plus
rapidement possible merci double pour
françois de boot merci karl mousseau
mercia c'est une émission réalisée par
adrie colruyt alix excusez moi rodrick
calixte et je vous souhaite une bonne
journée